-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with
Lin-Manuel Miranda.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We were talking
about "Encanto" earlier.
Congratulations on this, bud.
It is the biggest thing ever.
The soundtrack topped
the Billboard 200 chart
for nine weeks.
Soundtrack has sold
over 1 million copies.
"We Don't Talk About Bruno"
is the longest reigning
chart topper for Disney
in Billboard history,
making it the biggest
Disney song of all time.
-Yes! Thank you so much.
Thank you.
-No, that's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
But you -- you wrote
all these giant songs.
You wrote, like, eight of
these songs on the soundtrack.
That's amazing. You did this.
-It's crazy.
-Yeah.
-But have you ever
performed it?
-I never have.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Well, I thought maybe,
if you're on the "Tonight Show,"
we always have --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
I have --
If you don't mind, I have
a caterpillar costume for you.
-Well, now we have to do it.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, let's go.
-Alright? Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Ladies and gentlemen,
performing a medley of songs
from "Encanto,"
Lin-Manuel Miranda.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Dos oruguitas ♪
-♪ Enamoradas ♪
-♪ Pasan sus noches ♪
-♪ Sus noches ♪
-♪ Y madrugadas ♪
♪ Llenas de hambre ♪
♪ Siguen andando
y navegando un mundo ♪
♪ Que cambia y sigue cambiando ♪
♪ Navegando un mundo ♪
[ Tempo quickens ]
♪♪
♪ I'm the strong one ♪
♪ I'm not nervous ♪
♪ I'm as tough
as the crust of the Earth is ♪
♪♪
♪ I don't ask
how hard the work is ♪
♪ Got a rough
indestructible surface ♪
-♪ Diamonds and platinum ♪
♪ I find 'em, I flatten 'em ♪
-♪ I take what I'm handed
I break what's demanded ♪
♪ But under the surface ♪
♪ Berserk as a tightrope walker
in a three-ring circus ♪
♪ Under the surface ♪
♪ Was Hercules ever like, "Yo,
I don't wanna fight Cerberus?" ♪
♪ Under the surface ♪
-♪ I'm pretty sure I'm worthless
if I can't be of service ♪
-♪ A flaw or a crack ♪
-♪ The straw in the stack ♪
♪ That breaks the camel's back ♪
♪ What breaks
the camel's back, it's ♪
-♪ Pressure, like a drip, drip,
drip that'll never stop ♪
♪ Whoa ♪
-♪ Pressure that'll tip, tip,
tip 'til you just go pop ♪
♪ Whoa, oh, oh ♪
-♪ Give it to your sister,
your sister's older ♪
♪ Give her all the heavy things
she can shoulder ♪
-♪ Who am I if I can't run
with the ball? ♪
♪ If I falter ♪
♪♪
♪ Welcome
to the Family Madrigal ♪
♪ The home
of the Family Madrigal ♪
-♪ We're on our way ♪
-♪ Where all the people
are fantastical and magical ♪
♪ I'm part
of the Family Madrigal ♪
-♪ My tía Pepa ♪
♪ Her mood affects the weather ♪
♪ When she's unhappy ♪
♪ Well, the temperature
gets weird ♪
-♪ My tío Bruno ♪
-♪ We don't talk about Bruno ♪
♪♪
♪ We don't talk about Bruno,
no, no, no ♪
♪ We don't talk about Bruno ♪
-♪ But ♪
♪ It was my wedding day ♪
-♪ It was our wedding day ♪
-♪ We were getting ready ♪
♪ And there wasn't a cloud
in the sky ♪
-♪ No clouds allowed
-♪ Bruno walks in
with a mischievous grin ♪
-♪ Thunder ♪
-♪ You telling this story
or am I? ♪
-♪ I'm sorry, mi vida, go on ♪
-♪ We don't talk about Bruno ♪
-♪ No, no, no ♪
-♪ Did I talk about Bruno? ♪
-♪ We don't talk
about Bruno ♪
-♪ I never shoulda
brought up Bruno ♪
-♪ We don't talk about ♪
-All of these songs
were written by this guy,
Lin-Manuel Miranda, by the way.
He's awesome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Brunoooooo ♪
-Lin-Manuel Miranda, everybody!
Stick around!
We'll be right back
with Bobby Cannavale!
♪♪